[Music]
this morning in our saturday session
matt berninger
who was working in advertising in
cincinnati when he decided to turn his
passion for music
into his full-time job with friends he
moved to brooklyn new york and formed
the national the grammy-winning band
known for a series of critically
acclaimed albums
and unforgettable live shows now he's
also launched a solo career
we'll hear music from his just released
new album in a moment but first
anthony mason caught up with him
the last time we were
together when matt bernier made the
video for his new song
one more second
i got to like just just dance to the
song all day
covet precautions required a new
approach
[Music]
i think artists and people filmmakers
and musicians are all finding really
inventive ways
to do what they did before but with with
with their hands tied you know
suddenly everyone has to turn into
houdini you know they have to
berninger has more than a few tricks up
his sleeve
this year he's rehearsed with his band
worked on an opera and finished up his
first
solo album
[Music]
you can split yourself in all those
different directions yeah because
they're not different directions for me
they're all
i keep describing it as all in the same
soup of
of stuff i do say yes to too many things
and i do get really exhausted and cranky
and burned out
and um and uh you know and when berries
land on my head during interviews i
sometimes
lose it uh but i just i don't know
art and making stuff has always been the
thing that just
makes me feel feel happier it makes me
um
feel like i did something worthwhile
today and and you know made a scratch on
the universe
i see the start light through the clouds
bernina
is releasing his solo debut serpentine
prison
at age 49 but for the cincinnati-born
son of a lawyer
and teacher it's hardly his first
unexpected
career term i always have known i can
kind of
change whatever i'm doing anytime my
parents are always like do whatever you
want whenever you want
when i quit pre-med to study sculpture
you know my mom was like that's that
makes a lot of sense i like that that's
a good mom
yeah and then i went back to design and
i became a pretty successful designer in
new york city like a creative director
and then when i told my mom i was like i
want to quit that
and and and write love songs you know
and she's like i think she said like oh
well
finally both my mom and my dad have
always been like if it doesn't make you
happy
you're not successful i own them so much
[Music]
burninger was about to go out on an
asian tour
with the national when the corona virus
hit
mentally how are you doing in all of
this i'm doing good mentally and i've
been home
more than i've been home in 15 years and
it's been an
opportunity to really kind of rewire you
know i'm hanging out in the backyard
drinking wine during the day
in in you know being positive you know
it's working